c'est bien connu les français sont des
fainéants et l'oise yves temps la mère
de tous les vices la mettrait en danger
notre modèle social pour emmanuel macron
ses concitoyens ne travaillent pas assez
il l'avait déjà dit en 2019 en clôture
du grand débat il persiste et signe ça
fait toujours plaisir quand on se
compare nous sommes un pays qui
travaille moins que les autres en
quantité ça reste vrai et donc nous
avons une quantité de travail à louer
qui n'est pas au bon niveau à la fois
dans le cycle de vie en horaire cumulée
et au fond on a une force qui est notre
modèle social et éducatif mandat une
faiblesse c'est qu'on a plus le modèle
productif qui permet de le financer ah
mais alors nous n'avons pas dû lire les
mêmes chiffres officiels avec la dares
la direction de l'animation de la
recherche des études et des statistiques
évaluons le temps de travail
hebdomadaire des salariés en 2018 bon
les salariés français avec 36 3 heures
par semaine travaille davantage que les
danois 32,3 heures les allemands 34,8
heures les néerlandais 29,3 heures est
juste un tout petit peu moins que leurs
homologues britanniques 36 8 heures
espagnol 36,4 heures et juste pour info
les non-salariés hexagonaux ont eux
travaillé
43,9 heures par semaine en 2020 une
année chamboulée par la crise sanitaire
mais 45,3 en 2018 les chefs d'entreprise
les auto-entrepreneurs les travailleurs
indépendants se tuent bien à la tâche
alors pourquoi emmanuel macron dit il
que l'on travaille moins en france parce
qu'il ne se base que sur le temps de
travail annuel ils étaient deux mille
cinq cent cinquante heures en 2020 pour
les salariés français et en 2019 juste
pour les salariés à temps complet la
france de dépasser que la suède avec
d'autres chiffres fournis par l' ocde
pour l'emploi total c'est à dire les
salariés plus les non salariés en 2020
la france est mieux classée avec 1400
deux heures annuelles travaillé en
moyenne c'est plus que le royaume uni
avec 1367 heures l'allemagne 1332 mais
moins que la pologne 1766 ou la corée du
sud 1908 et si on comparer ce qui est
comparable en 2019 une année classique
la france était un peu mieux classé même
si elle était derrière belgique ou
l'espagne alors pourquoi ce classement
les français par plus tôt à la retraite
selon l'allusion au cycle de vie faite
par emmanuel macron et les salariés
hexagonaux dispose aussi en moyenne de
32 jours de congé par année en incluant
les rtt contre 25 pour la moyenne
européenne ah oui en fait on travaille
de manière intensive mais on a trop de
vacances c'est bien sûr mais si on a
ajouté la statistique primordial les
pays qui travaillent le plus en volume
horaire ne sont pas du tout les plus
productifs et dans ce domaine la france
est dans le peloton de tête au niveau de
son apport au pib par heure travaillée
elle écrase littéralement ses voisins
européens
elle rapporte 70 euros de l'heure contre
66 pour l'allemagne 52 pour l'espagne
focalisé son analyse sur une statistique
unique s'avère particulièrement
fallacieux d'autant que les problèmes
majeurs sont le travail partiel non
souhaitée et la moyenne du temps de
travail rapporté au nombre des actifs en
âge de travailler qui elle est
effectivement très faibles à cause du
nombre de chômeurs mais les français ne
sont pas à blâmer pour cela emmanuel
macron compte augmenter la durée légale
du travail et repousser l'âge de départ
à la retraite tandis que d'autres pays
sont jetés au contraire à la semaine de
quatre jours un débat réintroduit par
certains candidats de gauche à la
présidentielle au miracle les premières
expérimentations sont très prometteuses
en islande une étude menée sur 2500
salariés du privé et 440 fonctionnaires
passés aux 35 heures je rappelle que la
moyenne du travail hebdomadaire est
supérieur en france a été un succès et
en 2019 l'entreprise microsoft est passé
à la semaine de quatre jours au japon
dans un monde où les machines laisse
qu'on peu de travail aux humains le
président compte faire trimer les
français dommage que cette volonté soit
à rebours de l'époque et des idées
novatrices